the countdown to the new post-brexit
relationship was projected across the
departure gates
at the french side of the euro tunnel
rail link moments later
the first lorry was having its documents
checked
the trade deal agreed on christmas eve
means no tariffs and no quotas
but there is significantly more
paperwork and most of it needing to be
done
in advance the eurotunnel operator is
gettling
the change is really about a
custom formalities okay now each time
there is a truck coming here
they have to uh show us that they have
done
all their custom declaration online
before coming here
it's a significant change for logistics
and haulage firms on both sides of the
new trading frontier
the uk is expecting 220 million
additional customs declarations every
year
at a cost to business of some 9.5
billion dollars
the ferry crossing between the english
port of dover and calais in france
handles some 2.5 million freight
vehicles every year
but less than a thousand lorries were
scheduled to make the crossing on new
year's day
it's a gentle start for the new regime
many haulage companies
said they were holding off until the new
systems have bedded in
my hope is that given the opening couple
of weeks of january are generally pretty
late for us and with the pre-brexit
stock
build that we saw going on that that
should enable those people
that are trading during the period of
time to to train themselves and get used
to working in this new way
in fact at the gates of the port the
biggest sticking point on this first day
isn't brexit related at all
we had a plan all worked out all ready
to hold freight
to manage the freight but now we've had
to initiate
covert testing as well at a number of
locations so that's the biggest problem
that we've got because that was never
expected never planned for the key to
keeping the ports open and running
smoothly
will be the speed with which the
logistics companies get to grips with
the new electronic and paperwork
requirements
the early log jams are likely to be not
here at the ports
but back at the factory gate or
warehouse with cargo delayed because the
correct paperwork hasn't been filled in
these first quiet days of january an
opportunity for companies to familiarize
themselves with the new practicalities
the real test will come when trade
volume ramps up again
around the 10th or 11th of the month
paul brennan al jazeera dover